hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast exon level array bridging
the gap between chromosomal microarray
and next-gen sequencing presented by dr.
Nicole Dinu and dr. christina guzman oh
ozog I am Alexis Krause of laberd's and
I will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by laberd's and sponsored
by thermo Fisher Scientific for more
information about a sponsor please visit
thermo Fisher comm now let's get started
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button once there's many of
your questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left ear
screen this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits I'd like to now introduce our
speakers dr. Nicole Daly oh and dr.
Kristina Guzman oh ozog or complete
biographies on our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen dr. Daly you may now begin your
presentation all right good morning
everybody I'm happy to show you our
validation results of the new status can
exonerate that we tested in our lab in
the past two months in March and April
and just to let you know that we've been
using this side of scan HD array for all
nearly seven years now and weird
about two and a half thousand arrays a
year and for the HD it's known that it's
a very high-resolution array with
theoretical resolution of about one KB
and practical resolution of 20 KB the
detection criteria that we use in our
lab is that we have losses at least 10
KB in size with at least 10 probes for
games 20 KB in size and again more than
10 probes for the reporting criteria we
only report those TVs that we detect if
they're larger than 1 KB but if it's in
a region with an omen disease gene which
matches with the clinical features of
our patient than we also report smaller
CoV so larger than 20 KB on the other
hand if there's no protein coding gene
in the scene the region then we only
report the scene B if its larger than
500 Kb in addition to the side scan HD
array we also use C and V in our exome
data because we've been using whole
exome sequencing in our lab since 2011
and since 2014 we routinely also perform
seen via exome data analysis on all
exomes now the the average resolution
for the scene V in exome data is for a
50mm and the XO about 100 to 200 KB
genome wide but of course for the exomes
the targets are the exons and so for our
pipeline the calling criteria are at
least three exons then there is a call
and that's only done in line with
consent of the respective gene panel
that has been requested for a patient
now for the reporting criteria those are
also in line with consent so either gene
panel or gene panels and open exome for
both approaches both HD array and exomes
C and V we sometimes encounter
the envies that we need to validate they
were done unique needs that to do MLP a
so when we were informed that the situs
can excellent array was available in the
market last year we were very curious to
find out how well it performs especially
because they survey has almost 7 million
markers so we were quite impressed by
the number and therefore we decided - oh
that's right so the nice thing with the
exon array is that the probes are
highest coverage covered on the level 1
genes those are the ones with the
highest evidence for clinical relevance
so known disease genes and then the
other three levels have fewer probes per
exon but still are quite nicely covered
which you will see in a minute so as you
can see on this slide the level 1 genes
are targeted not only on the exon region
but also the flanking regions before and
after the exon whereas the level 2 & 4
genes are only targeted for the exon
itself within our validation study for
the site of scan excellent array we not
only looked at the Jeannette kinetics X
which is important but the majority main
thing is the QC parameters and we use
those settings those values that were
put up by thermal Fisher as depicted
here and then obviously also we would
like to determine the sensitivity the
specificity and the recruited
reproducibility then for the validation
study we performed a total of 78 arrays
in 9 runs with one run per week and
three technicians did all the work and
those were the three names that you saw
on the first slide now for the
validation purposes we used a thermal
Fisher DNA reference sample number 103
and we used that 13 times so on 13
arrays and in addition to that we had
DNA from five on effect
parents one DNA with the normal test
results after array whole exome and
whole genome sequencing and also a water
sample in addition to that we also had
in multiple samples with unknown seen be
detected by either a situs than HD scene
V in exome and or MLP a and also a
number of possible seeing these so we
were not quite certain whether or not
there that scene be was indeed a true
positive we not only use DNA from EDTA
blood but also from amnio sites as well
as fibroblasts we had 34 meal samples 23
female samples and one sample from a 46
xx mil 43 deletions were included and 12
gains and for seeing fees that were
needed to be validated by another test
so these are the results from the nine
different runs that we performed in our
lab this is the snip QC value as you can
see here should be larger than ten the
majority of the runs were fine only run
or was quite literate poor results but
all other runs were quite nicely below
the above 10 for the Madi the that
should be a value below 0.2 and again
only the the run number four did not
qualify here and again the waviness SD
which is an important QC parameter that
should be less than 0.8 and only when
four was really dramatically above all
others the majority was below but two
were sub-optimal now for the detection
of analysis you obviously need to set
your filters on the far left we we show
you the filter settings that we use for
our HD array and the
is those values that we set decided to
use for the exon array and if you do not
have any filter settings apart for the
for the size then you can obviously
detect more but you also get more noise
and here you see from one of the arrays
I show you the segment number that was
that were called and here you see 4663
and 172 and this is what it looks like
for the for the whole genome view and
the little bars here indicate the
segments that were cold now if you
compare inch as 3.3 how it looks for the
HD array and for the exon array you see
the copy number state indicated by a
triangle for the HD and by a vertical
bar for the exon the multi ratio are
basically the same only for the exon
array there is now also a summarized
lock to ratio for the genotype
information that's basically the same
for both platforms only for the exon
array you also have that so-called
Belial frequency that you can select for
viewing the nice thing is that within
chess you can load at the same time both
exon and HD array samples so you can
compare the two in one view so that we
really liked this is an example this is
a finding that we had in a boy
five-year-old with mild intellectual
disability and autism and there you see
that with the HD array we found a
hundred 180 KB deletion and it's in on
chromosome 18 including the TCF forging
now as you can see here this is the
exonerate result and you also see a
deletion but it's seemingly smaller
however this is where you need to look
at your graph settings because you need
to get a little use to the chess
settings so when you click here on
automatic dynamic range you clearly see
that the loss is much clearer with this
setting and therefore this was
confirming that this scene he was called
also by the exonerate let's see what do
they have here oh yes here I want to
show you the coverage of the probes for
various genes going from fairly large
genes such as TC f4 here you see it on
the HD array the probe coverage and here
you see the excellent coverage for that
for that specific gene the TCF for gene
now next one is the eh MT one the gene
known to cause high stress syndrome if
it's mutated or deleted again nice
coverage on both platforms but if you go
along this is right one also nicely
covered on both platforms but if you
notice that the smaller you get the
better the coverage is for the exon
array again this is still a nice
coverage on the HD but if you now look
at the ELN gene in the 7q one one two
three region you see that for the HD it
becomes more difficult here are the
different exons on in this gene and you
see a basically a gap here on the
coverage in the HD but the axon is
really nicely covered and even smaller
and their shops gene thirty-five KB in
size size but it's really nicely covered
on the exon array now I was curious to
see it just to see how many probes are
there on those specific genes that I
just mentioned for the x11 and exon five
here you see the number of probes for
the HD platform and there you see that
on the right hand side the axon of the
first on the on the excellent excellent
array a tremendous increased number for
the exon array so really impressive now
now I'm going to show you a few samples
from patients that were used for
validation purposes so this is the
this is MLP a and gene mutation analysis
that was performed for the SDK 11 gene
in a 15 year old boy boy with
pigmentation on his lips and a high
incidence of cancer in the family and so
the clinical suspicion of coats
Jagr syndrome and with the mo PA there
was a loss of as at least exons five to
ten for the STK
11 gene so the requesting clinician
wanted to know how big the actual D
deletion is so for characterization
purposes we use the situs scan HD array
and there we found 150 KB loss in
chromosome 19 however that was distal of
the STK 11 gene which was quite
surprising to us sooo so he used
different reference sets but nothing
changed for that matter we still did not
detect a deletion involving the SDK 11g
so therefore this was also a sample used
for validation on the exon array and
here you see the HD result and below the
result for the exon array and you
clearly see that this deletion is bigger
on the excellent array if you zoom in
then you see this is the the HD deletion
and this is the entire deletion on the
exon array and there this is zoomed in
here you see the aberrant region
detected by exon array and as you can
see on the left hand side the breakpoint
is in the SDK 11 gene and this is a 200k
B loss in excellent v the breakpoint is
in exon 5 of this gene which is an
agreement with the MLP findings
next is are the results of the array in
a boy a 7 years old with central sensory
neural hearing loss
first GJ be 2 & 6
sequence analysis did not reveal any
variants then exome gene panel was done
and there we found a nucleotide variant
on one allele and again on chromosome 12
undies we don't know but so we had a CMV
and an assembly in this boy
so this was one sample that we also
performed exonerate to validate the
finding with the C and V in exome
analysis therefore we focused on the
otaku gene in this case and this is what
it looks like this is the O toggle gene
here below and there you see the the
gain on the left hand side if you zoom
in you it looks like this and the first
six exons of this genes show a couple
number increase if you compare this with
the C and V and exome data it really
matches nicely with each other and one
reason to validate the finding of the
same thing in exome data is that the
finding the call for exon 2 was
seemingly normal but now with the
excellent array result we can confirm
that it's really the first 6 exons that
show a copy number gain next is an
example that was a newborn baby girl
prenatally already prenatal array was
performed did not reveal any imbalances
then terrible trio exome analysis was
performed with immune disease gene panel
there after open exome analysis but no
variants were identified then the
clinician requested re analyst analysis
of the data because the baby died at 7
months of age and then they asked us to
look at certain genes and one of them
was a de novo variant in the FET or gene
that is associated with a recessive
disorder so we were curious and we
wanted to know whether perhaps there is
a copy number gained or lost on the
other allele so we performed X
but unfortunately we did not reveal any
we did not detect any C&V there I
include this example this these data to
show you more on the nebula
gene because this is a quite large it's
an impressive number of exons for this
gene but it's also a difficult gene
because of the various repeats within
the gene and here you see the C and B
next some data and in the middle you see
a gap again and that's because in that
gap there's a repeat sequence and so
this region is not covered on the exome
so we were curious to see what those
data look like for the array again here
this is the region enlarged multiple
exons within that repeat region and this
is the result for the HD array the
prenatal HD of a result that does not
reveal anything any imbalance there's a
minor dip in the in the one region and
here with the axon array there seems to
be a loss in that repeat region so just
to make sure we did look in the exome
data again because of severe form of
nebula disease could also lead to
hydrops fetalis and that was also
encountered prenatally in this fetus but
we did not find any nucleotide variants
in this child in the nebula gene next is
an example again a prenatal array was
done because of nuchal translucency and
hydronephrosis after that was observed
at 19 weeks of gestation and there we
found a hundred and kb deletion in
chromosome six within the arid 1b gene
it turned out to be a de novo gene and
therefore this was also included because
it only had one exon deletion here it
was so it was a one
it was a de novo one exon deletion in
air on B as you can see here these are
the exon array below and there it's also
detected with this I assume in here and
there you see that that one exon is
clearly deleted and it's it seems
smaller but that's just because the
focus or the exon array is on the exons
next example we go even deeper than so
within an axon this was a finding we had
in a in a intrauterine fetal death at
333 weeks of gestation and there we
found a very small loss less than 1 KB
in size 8 probes and it was within
excellent one of the jak 1 gene and we
were curious to see how that looks for
the on the exon or a and sure enough the
deletion was indeed confirmed by the
exon array not only that also the
excellent 3 & 4 seems to show a copy
number game so we are not certain
whether that is a truly clinically
relevant but it definitely could because
those gains of 3 & 4 have been
recordings
reported in the jak 1 gene next are the
data of Eckstrom sequencing in a
seven-year-old boy where we did the
hearing loss gene panel no scene snv's
were found but with the C and B and X
own and confirmed by MLP a the probe and
had a homozygous loss of at least exons
25 through 29 of the STR C gene mother
turned out to be a heterozygous carrier
of a deletion but father reveals a
normal copy number for that region now
if you look at into that region on 15 q1
5.3 there's the SVR C gene there's the C
KMT 1b on the far left side and the
stars indicate the locations of the the
MLP MLP a probe also cover
by the MLP is the cat's birth to gene
because often you want to know whether
or not that gene is also deleted now the
problem or the challenge with the SARC
gene is that it's part of a tandem
duplication on chromosome 15 and the
second copy is in a in a pseudo gene so
that's really a challenge to to analyze
and interpret this gene so if you see
the HD coverage in this view of the UCSC
genome browser you see in complete
coverage of these two your C gene for
both the HD and as I indicated also for
the MLP a if you look on the exon array
it's really nicely covered for all exons
involved and we apply this we included
three samples from a trio so on the
upper left on the upper part of the
figure you see the homozygous loss of
the index patient you see the father who
shows a normal cup number and the mother
who has a heterozygous deletion in this
region so here you really see a nice
example of homozygous versus
heterozygous
so our conclusion for the validation
study results is that for the for all
the arrays that we performed we had to
conclude that one or meet more QC
parameters were not met in 53 percent of
78 arrays as far as the sensitivity is
concerned 46 percent was called with
filter settings that were you also used
for the HD 91% were called without
filter settings and all of them so a
hundred percent were visible in Chas
upon inspection as far as the
specificity is concerned non no
relevancy and these were detected and
reproducibility improves and is still
getting better with every run but I want
to show you next is that after having
run several well 76 array experiments
we decided to use a majority of those
data and use that as a new in-house
reference set and here you see in this
table the QC parameters for both old
reference set the ones the standard
reference said in our in-house excellent
reference set and you see that for all
QC parameters the values I have improved
indicated by the green collar only a few
red ones are shown or are seen and also
if you look at the far I'd and column
for the calls you really see a dramatic
improvement in the number of calls
because if you need to go over a hundred
the segment's or more than its that's
really tedious but if you stay within
between five and fifteen that's really
nicely doable so just a few more slides
to show you after the validation study
of a few results that we had made in the
recent weeks so one example is a
prenatal array request for because of
several structural ultrasound anomalies
the child was suspected to have Michael
Gruber syndrome and there we found a
very small deletion on chromosome 12
after the parents decided to terminate
the pregnancy because of the severe
ultrasound of structural abnormalities
after that seeing the in excellent trio
analysis was performed on DNA from the
the fibroblast from the fetus and there
we found an intra genic homozygous loss
in the t CT in one gene and that is the
same mas that we detected by HD array
and so we were wondering because there
it was a heterozygous loss or seemingly
heterozygous loss so we next performed
another HD array on the same sample as
was used on the CV in the exome data and
again it was identical to the previous
prenatal array Sam
so again this was strange to us that we
detected a heterozygous loss with array
but with exome he really saw a
homozygous loss and for the both parents
we saw a heterozygous loss for each of
them which matches with the fact that
the child has a homozygous loss so the
conclusion was that both our carrier of
the heterozygous loss and the child was
affected due to Holmes homozygous
homozygous loss in the t CT in one gene
now the parents are the couple is
pregnant again and they are thinking
about prenatal diagnosis so we were
wondering what the best test would be
and I said I would go for the exon array
so that was the next step we did we did
exon array and here you see the example
of the HD array below in light blue and
the the violet in the exon array on the
fetal DNA sample if you zoom in oh no
sorry and next we also did the mother
DNA on the exon array and here you
really see that in the fetus the there
is a homozygous loss whereas in the
mother there is a heterozygous loss so
that was matching with the scene being
exome data and as you also can see the
homozygous loss in the fetus is within a
relatively small homozygous region that
was we think due to identity by descent
which matches with the fact that both
parents have the same heterozygous loss
but no other almost like a CT detected
final slide and this was just because I
was curious to see how the coverage on
the exon array is for we non-coding
regions in the human genome and
especially especially the the enhancer
region upstream to the fox f1g9 16 q2
for one is known as an important region
to be able to detect or analyze because
that has been shown to if
deleted it can cause lvl Veiler
capillary dysplasia with misalignment of
pulmonary veins due to Fox f1
haploinsufficiency so that region is
nicely covered on the HD array but it
and if you look on the X on the Ray I
was happily surprised that that was also
really nicely covered and this is the
thing that that region is not covered on
the X own because it's not encoding so
in conclusion our validation study
results demonstrate that the situs can
HD array is a sorry the X the situs can
exonerate is a suitable suitable
platform to detect seen these at the
exon level that it yields really nice
results for various for with DNA samples
from various tissues and that it is
currently in my opinion the best option
to test multiple genes for intragenic
CNB's in the human genome because
definitely not for all genes there is a
MLP a test available and also
genome-wide analysis is possible within
for the exon array although it's lower
resolution than achieved with the HD
array but it's a higher resolution that
then you can achieve with C and v-necks
own data so with this I with I turned
and thank my colleagues in the
department and I'm happy to answer any
questions you might have
thank you thank you for inviting me to
share this presentation with you today I
will discuss our experience with the
ex-owner day but a confessional in
Washington DC at first like to give an
overview over copy number variation as
we're all aware this is an important
determinant of human diversity and plays
a significant role in disease
susceptibility there's about 1.2 percent
difference between any individual in the
reference genome in an exact study of
almost 6,000 individuals over 100 26,000
copy numbers of variants were noted in
protein coding team
and on average most individuals have
about 0.8 deleted and 1.75 duplicated
genes in their genome most individuals
will carry at least one rare gem at copy
number variants of these changes 84% are
smaller than 100 Kb and 50% are shorter
than 20 KB
children's national is one of the
largest clinical genetics programs in
the United States and last academic year
approximately 8,000 individuals were
seen in the genetics clinic the
individuals evaluated in clinic are a
very generous group of the 8,000
approximately 500 were noted to have
developmental delay another 500 remanded
to hold autism and a little over a
thousand were seen because of an inborn
error of metabolism and as we're all
aware the evaluation of the case in the
genetics clinic often includes
recommendation for genetic testing in
2013 we went live with chromosomal
microarray and at that time we're using
the site of an HD system as we're all
aware this was a first tier test for the
evaluation of imbalances associated with
intellectual disability autism and
multiple congenital anomalies in August
of 2014 we transitioned over to the
Saito scan the X system
it's a 510 K cleared chromosomal
microarray there's a post natal use for
cases of developmental delay
intellectual disability multiple
congenital anomalies or dyslexic
future's following our goal life of
homazooma microarrays we proceeded to
insource next-gen sequencing in 2015 we
went live with next-gen sequencing and
our approach was to use a medical exome
kit as opposed to going live with whole
exome sequencing in our laboratory
setting we treat all samples the same on
the wet bench and sequence all genes for
for example we done violin thematically
filtered the genes to only those that
were ordered for education this allows
physicians to order either a predefined
panel such as party of myopathy neumann
or epilepsy or this allows the physician
to order a custom panel based on either
a phenotype driven approach based on the
clinical indications noted in their
clinical evaluation and it also allows
us to leverage our microarray results so
you look for a recessive disorders in
areas of homozygosity this is especially
important in our patient population as
approximately 5% of all microarray
results in our laboratory of greater
than 2.5% areas of homeless optic
acetate consistent consequently
additionally if testing is negative we
allow the physicians to have a
three-second lock which minimizes cost
and analysis time in the lab in hopes of
also decreasing the number of the us's
that the physician who sleeps on the
report even with moving forward with
next-gen sequencing there was a strong
desire from our clinicians to also have
P and B analysis as part of the testing
we then decided to approach the
validation of CMV analysis via our
next-gen sequencing the way we approach
this is by using bwa and gatk to Pauls
snv's and short in bells the BAM file is
then fed into the next gene software and
this detects copy numbers by comparing
the coverage of the sample to the
coverage of controls coverages measured
as a standard and probabilities are
entered into a new Markov model during
our validation of copy number bio
methodically we examined 122
CNB's 109 were previously discovered by
another method or an outside laboratory
please included 66 deletions and 43
duplications
additionally 7 negative samples were
verified
ordering our validation for signalex on
copy number it's failed to be detected
and two single axon that had not been
previously identified were thought to be
found by it or validation as you can
imagine this was less than acceptable
when we were doing our validation and
really made us cautious and saying that
we were doing a good job on puppy number
analysis by next-gen sequencing single
exons is a known limitation of
bioinformatics copy number analysis and
and even though it's a known limitation
it still made us uncomfortable to
declare that we were able to do this
appropriately so four of the eleven that
were single axon four were not
identified during our validation and
even if we were to have moved forward
and called this a validated process we
realized that there was still a need for
an additional confirmation of NEC and we
call that would be reported out and so
the question came up of would we use an
alternate platform or would we use a
secondary method of C and D calling such
as Bayesian analysis thankfully as we
were in this conundrum
satis can exonerate became available and
so we first started utilizing exon array
in April of 2017 and that was really
just the process of getting to know the
workflow and the web bench and being
able to process samples we completed our
training in October and kids are now
available for use for all individuals
hits can be used with the existing
thermo scientific equipment ie if you
have the sight of scant HD or DX system
from your laboratory you can supplement
the equipment already in your laboratory
by purchasing this kit and one of the
really neat things that we were able to
accomplish in our lab
is that the medical technologist that is
assigned to proper sinus can DX assay
which was run on a weekly basis can also
run the site of scan X on concomitantly
which meant at least in our laboratory
setting no additional have two e's were
required to bring this additional tests
in-house so quickly to compare the DX
and X on arrays the DX array has 2.7
million markers for copy number analysis
there are approximately 880 bases apart
and which is Jenna genic regions and
approximately 1700 bases apart and
non-genetic reasons additionally there's
750,000 snips to aid in the detection of
homozygosity and or unit parts with ice
cream comparing this to the exon array
the exonerate has 6.5 million from so
it's significantly larger number of copy
number groves
however it has significantly less snip
probes with only 300,000 the DX system
is meant to cover the entire chromosome
and in broad swoops whereas the exon
array is really focused on genes of
interest with the level 1 genes being
genes that are in omen with more disease
with phenotypes and moving down to
levels two three and four that are
beings with significantly less knowledge
known about them I would like to talk
about some clinical cases that we have
had in our laboratory setting to compare
and contrast and to illustrate by unit
but I should also mention at this time
that with the DX system the filters are
locked down the filters for deletions
are set at 25 KB and twenty-five markers
and duplications are set at 50 KB and
fifty markers the exon and HD systems
allow you to alter the filtering
settings and so therefore that can
result in some differences in some of
the cases that I will show you in the
first case I'd like to describe was an
adult male assistant
versus we perform CFTR full sequencing
and identified one mutation which is a
known pathogenic mutation and that sound
21 it is associated with pancreatic
insufficiency however no second hit was
fun
it doesn't change this person's clinical
diagnosis whoever it is unsatisfying to
not detect the second mutation
additionally our copy number analysis by
automatically failed to detect a
deletion or duplication we therefore ran
the sample on the exon array kit and
detected a deletion of exons 19 and 20
in the CFTR gene providing the molecular
conformation of this patients wonderful
diagnosis of cystic fibrosis the second
case I'd like to share with you is a 21
month old female who presented to the
hospital with luckily altered Mental
Status metabolic acidosis interrupted by
Alexis additional studies to evaluate a
fatty acid oxidation defect where
negative and the next step was to
proceed with a small next-gen panel of
genes associated with after meiosis
during that evaluation a likely pathogen
the kind of change in life and one was
identified this variant is located at
the splice site of inch one pen changes
in life in one are associated with acute
recurrent myoglobin area an autosomal
recessive disorder and typically
individuals will either be compound
heterozygous or homozygous for mutations
and I can walk however again similar to
our previous case no second hit was
found this also includes a copy number
by bioinformatic analysis we then ran
the sample on the exon array and
detected a deletion of exons 20 and 21
and open one so this is two different
cases now where an individual was
identified to have a 2x on deletion in
the gene and the recessive disorder that
was not found by next-gen sequencing or
by Owen for that
remember these three is a infant with
multiple osteochondromas and I have
shared with you a slide of the left hand
showing you the arrows where that some
of the osteochondromas were identified
in this individual so clinically we know
that this is the appropriate date that's
just a significant role in looking at
the gene reviews individuals with
hereditary osteochondromas typically
have alterations of eft-1 orts field and
of these cases about 10% will be due to
a poppy number difference as opposed to
8a snv year and we ran the CX array in
part because the clinician had ordered
it not necessarily looking for a
deletion of exp one or two but really
just looking for any sort of large scale
for further collaborations and on the DX
assay there were no calls made and the
result was a negative report that was
generated we then followed up with
next-gen sequencing with exp 1 & 2 and
we were able to identify the deletion
bioinformatics li and so we decided to
run this on our exon array so that we
can compare it to the DX array
information on the exon array it did
note the deletion that backs 1 5 through
7 and the sp1 and so when we went back
to review to the vs array although there
was milk all generated this was likely
because it was less than the 25 markers
in 25 KB that are required for the DX to
make a call you can note on the raw data
that there is a little dip where iPhones
five years are gonna cut case number
four is an 8 year old male with a
history of pain and his lower
extremities possible muscle weakness
mild optic atrophy
and frequent following the family
history was significant for
consanguinity and the DX array was run
in part to look for areas of
homozygosity to then narrow down the
possibilities of a recessive disorder
the patient was identified to have
almost 21% of the autos I go as being
homozygous which resulted in and a large
number of genes when I read this testing
also identified an uncertain hall that
was a homozygous on 190 Facebook kami
deletion at chromosome 4q and so this is
a gene in which deletions of exon 2 have
been associated with charcot-marie-tooth
type of disease and when we looked at
the DX raw data you can see the large
area block of homozygosity and
additionally you can see the homozygous
deletion what occurs within that block
of public eye Gossett however we didn't
have a really good feel for whether or
not the deletion was intronic or whether
or not it spilled out into the exons and
because there are few sports of
deletions of X onto the disease pausing
in this disorder we went ahead and ran
the X on the Ray in reviewing the calls
generated by the software system there
was no call in this gene however if you
look at the raw data you can see this
deletion between exons 1 into this made
us feel a little more confident that we
weren't missing a diagnosis in other
words the data appears to be pretty
solid or the exon 2 and that genetic
information is present the next case I'd
like to share with you is a urea cycle
disorder and this was a female who was
born and identified to have
hi grandma me Mia and be saturations and
with biochemical testing was identified
to have the proximal urea cycle be back
so in other words there was a very low
level of citrulline and the differential
diagnosis for urea cycle disorder with
absence of citrulline includes OTC CP s
1 and s so despite having a very clear
biochemical diagnosis molecularly the
diagnosis can still be baked in the
situation's because of her also being an
infant of a diabetic mother and having
additional complications on top of the
hyper and anemia
there was concern for the possibility of
a second disorder or something larger
happening on a chromosomal level Marie
was ordered testing did not identify any
copy number changes however it did
identify four percent of the atoms I go
I'm a big again consistent a family
interestingly we noted a large AOH
region by chromosome 2 Q 3 4 and in that
large AOH region includes the CPS
lunchmeat as I mentioned before using
the DX platform there was no deletion
identified within this block of AOH
however when we ran the sample on the
exon array we noted a homozygous
deletion of exon 32 and so looking at
the D s raw data I have drawn in an
arrow to show you that there is an
absence of probe coverage over exon 32
in the CPS 1 gene however when you look
at the exon array raw data you can
clearly see very good coverage of exon
32 and this small tip that shows it's
just that exon that is deleted this next
case is a incidental finding that was
noted on a male child with a history of
seizures who had undergone a
Brants of epilepsy panel that was not
diagnostic the physician decided to
follow up with sinus candy acts my
favorite water and testing identified a
200kg deletion 17th of uncertain
clinical significance because within
this region there are three genes listed
in omen including PMS two pianist two is
one of four known genes known as
hereditary nonpolyposis colorectal
cancer so this was an uncertain call to
make and a otherwise healthy male child
with male family history of cancer and
looking at the DX Thea we saw that the
deletion spanned into PMS - but again
did not feel confident on which portion
of part of PMS - was actually deleted in
this patient follow-up testing that exon
array identified a deletion of one of
the exons within PMS - so although the
data is a little bit different this may
be in part because we're comparing HD 38
say 19 it was reassuring that there
definitely is deleted material at PMS -
and reporting this out in a male child
was an appropriate thing to do
well last piece I want to share with you
is the piece of mosaic 29 um just to
illustrate what mosaic cases look like
from both the DX and Exxon systems so
this was a newborn male with
micrognathia rough palate VSD first to
kidney and hypospadias who had had a
normal prenatal microarray by
amniocentesis because of the multiple
congenital anomalies the clinician
ordered site of scan DX microarray and
the findings were consistent with mosaic
personally 9 the position then decided
to follow up with karyotype and fish
studies to determine the true level of
mosaicism results of that additional
testing identified two of 50 metaphase
cells with trisomy 9 and interphase fish
on a direct sample
indicated that about twenty point five
percent of solid currently life so for
fun we ran this on the X on the Ray and
compared it to the DX RA and what you
can note is that both platforms both
called the mosaic Christ semi mine and
so I just like to conclude with how we
envision using X own array in our
laboratory as individuals are evaluated
in the genetics clinic if they are
identified to have intellectual
disability multiple congenital anomalies
or the smoker futures are off of them
situs can be X is still the first two
your tests that we use in our laboratory
setting in part because it is FDA
cleared and if negative then we will
work with the ordering Commission's to
follow up with either next-gen
sequencing and our site of an exon all
right depending on the food with height
if there is a suspected diagnosis of
some individual the physician will order
next-gen sequencing or singer
confirmation of the single gene and
again if that pulsing is negative or
one-hit as identified in the recessive
disorder with no second met we will
follow up with site ask an exon array to
see if there is a cnv that was missed by
the bioinformatics following system
additionally although we do not offer
whole exome sequencing in-house when
whole exome sequencing returns from an
outside laboratory with one hit in a
recessive disorder we again can follow
up with excellent array to see if a
second hit was missed and so with that I
would like to acknowledge the laboratory
at Gillian's national crystal Ralphy
bizarre medical technologist who has
done all of the what let's work through
the exonerate cases I've defended Oh dr.
Meltzer has been conforming the Delta of
analysis by automatically for us and
Mary Beth is our genetic counselor those
peoples organized the Lompoc
and so with that I would like to open
this up to any questions that you may
have and thank you for your time thank
you dr. daylian dr. Kuzma
ozog for your informative presentation
it is now time for our live Q&A portion
of the webinar before I begin a poll
will pop up on your screen if you have
questions or would like additional
information on the site Oh scan Exxon or
a please check all that apply a member
of our team will contact you shortly
now if you have a question you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
answer question box located on the far
left to your screen and we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question is is going is going to be for
dr. daylian how do you explain the
significant improvement in QC parameters
when using your in-house reference set
for array data analysis well that is
actually not really new because we also
observed that with our status scan HD
array and also with 250k snip array that
we used in the past it's really crucial
to use your own process data for within
your reference set because of minor
differences and also sort of the the lab
person's signature that is is more or
less visible in in the data and we were
actually quite pleased with with the
significant improvement so we were happy
with the result as you can imagine now
dr. cusamano ozog this one is for you do
you perform Saito scan DX and exon array
on all samples um thanks for that
question
no we do not perform both the X and X
found on all samples so in other cases
that I Illustrated today we did run both
in parts to just demonstrate the
differences between the platform and we
offered ZX as
to stand alone to ask them that it is
our microarray assay of the place and
that is what the positions are ordering
if they want to write we are using
epsilon to supplement that's our
nabu-san pipeline as well as to
supplement any sort of questionable
calls that are made with the via now we
are getting so many good questions today
but we do only have time for a couple
more so dr. Daly oh why does the exon
array have better exon coverage than
your average whole exomes excuse me
whole exome sequencing data set
well I mean I can basically only draw
the conclusion based on on the exome
that we use and that's the 50 and B
exome enrichment and that's because the
focus of the exome is on the coding
sequences coding axons and with the exon
array we have experienced and I've seen
that also the non coding exons are
included on the coverage and that was
that makes the big difference especially
for exon 1 which is often not or not
very well covered excuse me
so that's the big difference coding only
or coding and non-coding it is it okay
that question absolutely
so I would say you know in our
experience when when we're looking at
copy number bioinformatics we're
comparing to other samples within that
run you know anything that's not well
covered across all samples like you
mentioned that someone are difficult to
pick up by Owen thematically
additionally a small deletions of one or
two exons are also equally difficult
since I got by a beautiful thing about
the excellent memory is that you're
really looking at that specific patient
that individual sample and those probes
are specifically designed that was great
input thank you doctor cusamano's ugh
and it looks like we have time for one
more question so
dr. Kuzma ozog how hard was it to
implement exon array in your lab it was
honestly one of the easiest things we've
done in our lab since we started growing
in 2013 um so the beauty of the exon
array is we have all that equipment
instrumentation already available in the
lab it really was just plug and play
with a new kit the techs were very
comfortable with doing what bat-crap it
didn't take them a lot of time to learn
how to figure it out and additionally
they were able to really run it at the
same time that they're already running
the DX array kit so I'm gonna have to
eat standpoint it was really great from
my standpoint on the software analysis
side having had experience with the HP
software it really was sort of you know
dusting off the bike and getting back on
it all of the clicking and squeaking was
all very palpable before we go I'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions questions that we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information that you provided at the
time of the registration we would like
to thank our doctors for their time
today and their important research we
would also like to thank laberd's and
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through February of 2019 laberd's will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye